hey everyone this is kevin from
thechesswebsite.com and today we're
going to be looking at an
in game with two pawns versus a rook and
these two pawns are about to promote
down here to the first rank
turn into whatever they want from
white's standpoint the rook by itself is
not going to be able to hold
the fort against these two pawns pushing
down here
near the first rank here white is gonna
need to get his king
involved into the game we're gonna look
at the optimal lines from both side but
then also look at some of the
sub-optimal lines of
how things can go wrong for either side
of the board hopefully this will give
you a better idea of how you should be
thinking about the in-game
when you don't have some concrete ideas
on how
either side would win two pawns in a
rook clearly white is up in material
but right now black has the upper hand
because of the immediate threats of
these pawns pushing forward
to promote hopefully you enjoy this
video it's white's move first thing that
we need to do is get the king
involved into the game and that is king
to
g4 we said the rook by itself is not
going to be able to hold
the forward here now black has these two
past pawns
you need to push or pass pawns now
there's a few instances where
you need to develop other material to
get them to a position where you can
successfully push those pawns but
generally you do want to be pushing
those pawns
no different in this example black needs
to be playing either e2
or d2 look at both of those first
looking at e2
here and this is threatening this rook
here on
f1 so that the rook really needs to move
here
now if there wasn't connected pawn here
on
then it's usually safe to just play rook
to e1 this stops the immediate
threat of the pawn pushing forward down
to e1
but you can see that this loses to d2
now it can't be in front of either of
these pawns or it's going to lose and if
the rook comes over here to let's say a1
then d1 turning into a queen
and there's no way to stop the threat of
the pawn pushing down here to e1
if it takes here the pawn just going to
recapture and turn into a pawn so that's
not going to work
white does have the move after
e2 to bring the rook to
c1 or to f4 both of these are going to
put the opponent
in check force the king to move and then
depending on where black moves has
the next move to kind of figure out what
option is best
but of the two options rook to c1 is the
better option because
it not only attacks the king but still
protects this first rank
two pawns pushing forward you still want
to make sure that you have all your
material protecting
this first rank
now the king is under attack the most
logical move is to play king 2d4
still connected centralized king
protecting these pawns right here
if the king starts going over to the b
file doesn't make a lot of sense
completely disconnected from the rest of
the pieces here
so king d4 most logical move and now
that the rook on c1 is not
under attack why can continue with the
initial theme we talked about and that
is to get the king here on g4
more involved into the game f3 the
immediate move for white here now we
start to look at black's options he
can't just play
pawn to e1 because that's just going to
get captured by
the rook on c1 then we start to look at
the king here
the king can't come to e3 or e4 because
it's now blocked by
the white king here it can't come to any
of the squares
on the c file because it's blocked by
this rook here on c1
and it doesn't make a lot of sense for
the king to move up here on
d5 because then just king to e3
and that stops all the threats that
black has and now black is actually
going to
lose this game so the only real threat
that black has to continue
is d2 and that is a very real threat
here because
that puts a lot of pressure on whites
not only from the rook standpoint but
also
both of these pawns are getting ready to
push forward here
and now white has a very interesting
move to find
but he wants to make sure that the king
stays disconnected from
these pawns it would be great if
white could just take here on e2 but the
threat right now is that the pawn
captures on
c1 and then white's going to lose this
game so he needs to make sure that the
king
stays distant and that the black pawn
here on d2 cannot capture the rook
on c1 and white does this by playing the
move rook
2 c4 check you can see that if black
takes here on c4 then white takes on e2
and it doesn't really matter where black
goes if he tries to hold on to it that's
fine
white can play king 2 d1
and this is stopping the king coming
down to c2
and so the only real move that black has
is either d3 which this is stalemate or
to play maybe something like king to b2
but then the pawn is going to fall so we
can clearly see that if the king takes
here on c4
that's going to end up in a draw which
is what white's going for the other
option would be
to play king to d3 now the king is more
connected to the pawns than it was even
on d4 so white has to continue the same
idea
does not just want to play c3 because
that's still going to connect it to
the pawns but instead plays the move
rook 2
d4 now this says if you want to take the
material
the king can take here on e2 and the
king is not connected so
if it does come back here to c3 white
has the same thing as before
this is going to end in a stalemate
white king cannot move it's not under
attack this is going to be a drawn game
this is exactly what white is
going for now if the king here on d3
says i still refuse to take this
material
maybe i go king to c3 here
well now just the king's not protecting
that pawn here on
e2 can take here probably not going to
push down here to a d1 because then the
rook can take it
pretty much black is forced to take this
rook here and then
the king is going to take here on d2
so that was a breakdown if the pawn
moves to e2
first but let's look at d2 as well
because the rook on f1 is not under
attack like it was with
black playing e2 white can now play
king 2 f3 the rook here on f1 is still
protecting this first rank that's
exactly where white wants it
but he does need to get the king
involved into the game as
fast as possible now from black's
standpoint black
really needs to get his king evolved
into the game here to d3
we can already see that d1 loses to the
rook just taking here on d1
and if the pawn comes down here to e2
then we can also just see that the king
takes here on e2
and then if maybe king 2 c3 then
rook to d1 and the pawn is going to fall
and
black is going to lose this game so
black in this position
has to play king 2 d3
now white really wants to get the king
to e2 so he has to have an
in-between move right now and that move
is rook to
a1 the king here on d3
cannot move to e4 or e2
and if he moves away from
this d-file then the king can come to e2
which is the optimal square
for the king black can't push forward
here with d1 he's going to lose that if
he pushes forward here with
d2 then white has the move rook to a3
this is attacking the king here and the
king has a couple options
the worst option would be to move up
towards the fourth rank
if he does that then white can just take
here on e2
the king can no longer come past this
third rank and his pawn is going to fall
and so black could play king to c2
in this example rook down here to a2 and
if black
keeps pushing here to b1 then white can
capture with this king here on e2 and it
may look like okay we'll now
just don't want to lose the rook let's
go ahead and capture here on d2 you
always have to be thinking about what
your opponent can do
because now black has the move pawn to
e1 promoting to a queen so you don't
want to do that you don't want to take
with your rook here
white is just going to capture with the
king here on
e2
in the first few examples we looked at
what happens if black pushes the pawns
and that's exactly what black needs to
do put
maximum pressure on white white has to
play optimally just to draw the game
but this is a fragile position if black
plays his king first white actually wins
the game by playing well
not just trying to hold on for a draw i
can win
before we get into that just want to
thank you so much for watching this
in-game series i am going to be putting
out a ton of content if you wouldn't
mind
hitting that like button let me know
that you support these videos as well as
not only subscribe but hit that
notification bell i do want to make sure
that you are aware of all the videos
that i'm going to be putting out for
this series
they're going to be coming out a lot
more frequently than i've done in the
past don't want you to miss anything so
we'll go ahead and get into it
let's say that the move is king to c3
because the rook on f1 is not under
attack white can play
king 2 f3 here and then how does black
really continue well you have the
obvious moves of
pawn to d2 well that loses to king takes
on e3
that's not very good let's say that king
comes to d2 and just says
i want to get all up in the action here
well now we have the move rook to h1 and
it's sort of a waiting move
because if the king moves away
to let's say c2 well then white can just
start to gobble up pawns here
and let's say they play the move e2
well now the move king to f2 and things
get trickier the
king here on d2 can't move to e3
it can't move to any of the squares on
the first rank because of the rook here
so the king is forced to move back and
now the king can come to e3 critical
square because it stops more of the
squares that the black king wants to go
to d2 and d4
so now maybe we see the king come to c2
and now a waiting move from whites rook
to g1
you're just you have the position right
now
black can't really do anything if in
this position right here if they just
play
uh pawn to d2 well now just
king takes here on uh e2
and even if you have king to c2 you
could just play rook to g1
sort of as a waiting move they they
can't just push forward here
and the king can't do anything as soon
as the king moves then just rook to d1
you're just always trying to put your
position your opponent in
the worst position possible so let's say
in this position
uh that the king comes to c2 we play
that weighty move of rook to g1
now they come back with king to c3 here
now rook to c1 and where do they really
go you can see that they can't come to
d4 or d2 because of our king here
they can't stay on this c file anymore
so they've got to move away and as soon
as they move away
let's say king to b3 then white can
start to gobble up the material
right here
now backing up a few moves we've already
taken a look at if the pawn comes to d2
then that fails because this leaves the
pawn hanging here on e3
and king to d2 also doesn't work the
example we just looked at but
e2 makes a lot of sense it's protected
by the pawn here on d3 it's attacking
the rook as soon as our rook is under
attack we know we need to move it
now before in our very first example
when the king was up here on c4
we played rook to c1 that doesn't work
anymore because the king can come to d2
now if we could play rook to c1 and the
king couldn't come to d2
that would be a win but right now it can
so that's not going to be the optimal
move instead
white can play the move rook to h1
they still can't push forward with their
pawn here on e2
or with e1 and they can't just play d2
because then we would just capture their
material here on e2
so they're probably going to play king 2
d2
now ideally the white king here on f3
would like to come to e3 the reason for
that is that would stop
this black king from being able to come
here to d2
but right now it's occupying that square
so white has to figure out a way
to get the own king here to e3 and keep
the black
king from coming here to d2
so white has an in-between move of king
to f2
now this is stopping the king here on at
d2 it can't come to e3 and it still
can't come to the first rank here
because of the rook here
and so it's going to move let's say king
to c2
now we come to king d3 we
have gotten our square so it's always
good to figure out your game plan figure
out what squares you want your pieces to
go to especially in the end game
and see if you can make your opponent in
a position where they
have no option except to move away from
those squares it's a little easier to do
with a king
because they can never go to a square
where they're under attack so the king
can't come to the first rank it can't
come here to d2
so it's forced to move probably here to
c3 and now the rook can swing over here
to c1 we already talked about this is a
fine square
as long as the king can't come here to
d2
and we're starting to block off some of
the squares that the the black king can
go into can't stay on
uh the second rank so can't come to c2
can come to d2 or d4 because of the king
here so
uh maybe king to b2 attacking our rook
but now this just loses to king to d2
protecting our rook here and then these
pawns are going to fall
as well rook to e2 makes a lot of sense
as the next move depending on where
black goes remember black king can't
come to this c file anymore so it's
going to be in itself position can't
come down here to b1
so it's going to be playing something
like king to b3 completely out
of the game and then king takes on
d3 so there's a lot of complexity that
goes into
just this in game right here when you
look at it
if you haven't studied in games quite a
bit it could be overwhelming at first
in this series i'm going to be going
over hopefully it makes a lot more sense
if you have some some specific end games
you would like me to take a look at feel
free to send me those
but really open for ideas and feedback
on
this series so again if you wouldn't
mind please hit that like button thank
you guys so much for watching
uh this series let me know what you
think if you want me to just
do a ton of these videos every single
week if you want one every day
if you want more than that uh
less than that just let me know what you
guys are thinking i want to make sure
that you have the content that you're
looking for but thank you so much for
watching
and i'll see you in the next video
you